Welcome back everyone this will be my full ms
marvel episode 5 video there were a whole bunch
of easter eggs and references we'll break it all
down if you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the episodes because
thor love thunder is also out this week we're
also doing a giveaway for movie tickets all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber and just
post all your ms marvel theories on the video
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen the
episode yet we'll just start at the beginning
and go through shot by shot talking about easter
eggs and wtf moments as we go along the big
thing is they just confirmed a lot of theories
that people had about what really happened
in the past to the great-grandmother aisha
in what's going on in present day with comrade's
mother najma i know there's a lot of questions
with the mechanics behind the way their powers
work especially at the end of the episode too
like how she able to transmit all of her power
to comron so instantaneously as she was dying
i'll talk about that when we get to that part
of the episode but the actual episode title was
called time and time again it's a reference to
ms marvel time traveling in actually witnessing
the events of her grandmother's stories the
day at the train station during partition
is sort of setting off a grandfather paradox
situation where she becomes the person who helped
herself become ms marvel in the future by saving
the grandmother who had the bengal in the past
the actual episode starts with an old hindi song
playing over a custom black and white new version
of the marvel studios logo in the intro as if we
were watching a marvel movie in the late 1940s
with that level of technology they did the exact
same thing during the first couple of episodes of
one division that were set during previous eras
of television with different levels of technology
so the video is made to look like we're watching a
british broadcast during the 1940s and the opening
scene is of an actual british broadcast about the
partition getting ready to happen august 15 1947.
this would have been a couple years after captain
america had gone into the ice during world war ii
peggy carter would have already started working at
the ssr which was the precursor agency that became
the modern day shield organization obviously
before captain america winter soldier happened
so while this is playing out during this era
we would have had young dominic cooper looking
howard stark the younger version of jarvis on the
peggy carter tv series we also saw older jarvis in
the 1970s with an older version of howard stark
played by john slattery during avengers end game
during the time heist mission they kept the same
version of jarvis who just gave him old age makeup
but obviously they'd already used a slightly
different version of howard stark in the iron
man movies so they wanted to keep it being john
slattery instead of just putting old age makeup
on dominic cooper during avengers end game in
all the footage explaining the actual partition
here at the beginning of the episode is meant to
be real historical footage taken from that era
it is all accurate it explains pretty much what
partition is how they divided the original larger
country of india up after the british basically
left it to itself pretty much creating the modern
country of pakistan as you know it now forcing a
massive number of people to be relocated to the
newly created pakistan including kamala khan's
family because they were muslim they flashed
back a couple times in the episode to earlier
periods to explain the birth of her grandmother
but the period that kamala travels back to
is just that moment at the train station
during the actual partition the last day on the
train that her grandmother kept telling them about
we then flash back to 1942 in the moments meant to
be her great grandmother running from the british
soldiers immediately after they all take off
from the ten rings temple like directly after
this moment and they have another custom version
of the standard ms marvel tv show comic book title
sequence too this time done in hindi characters
and the art style is meant to be in a traditional
style just meant to reference the events of the
episode taking place mostly in the past obviously
she comes back to the future at the end of the
episode but most of the episode took place during
the 1940s and after another short time jump we're
just meant to see her great-grandmother seeing her
great-grandfather for the first time talking about
gandhi here in the town they explained how they
met and how her grandmother was eventually born
how they formed a family and why she decided not
to try and go back to their alternate dimension
just because she had this new family to protect
and she cared more about them than she cared about
going home also probably didn't want to try and
blow up half the planet in trying to go home or
consume the planet as the red daggers explained
in last week's episode like oh yeah if they were
actually trying to go back we would get absorbed
into the other dimension it would just consume
this entire dimension eventually which kind
of winds up playing out towards the end of the
episode until najma sacrifices herself to close
the barrier it's not so much an explosion is more
of them being absorbed kind of like we saw during
the first doctor strange movie with dormammu
trying to basically take over the entire main
dimension by absorbing it into the dark dimension
we find out that the poem that kamala found etched
on the bengal was her great-grandfather's poem
which itself is based on a classic poem that's
much much older it says when the soul lies down in
the grass the world is too full to talk about it
what you seek is seeking you in the poem just
in general is about achieving a more enlightened
state of existence like letting go of ego and
ascending to a higher level of existence just
simply choosing a higher version higher expression
of yourself which i think they're using in the
episode to be a metaphor for kamala khan sort of
transcending herself and becoming the superhero
version of herself like becoming full comic book
ms marvel also learning to use her power without
the actual bengal itself they teased that a couple
times during the episode because you see a couple
different characters using their newer power
without the actual bangle they also use the poem
what you seek is seeking you to be a reference to
the end of the episode when the great-grandmother
aisha tries to use her power to bring the
grandmother who's a little girl back from the
future to be the one to save herself but it winds
up pulling kamala the great-granddaughter instead
that's why when she first sees kamala khan she
mistakenly thinks that it's her daughter i think
the idea of their connection with their power
across space and time is also meant to reference
what's happening with komron at the end of the
episode basically getting his powers activated
by his mother when she sacrifices herself it's
kind of that same biological connection that they
have even though they don't totally explain that
don't worry i'll get into that later in the video
too like how exactly are they connected with their
power their biology but when they actually flash
forward to the birth of her grandmother you notice
aisha is wearing the same outfit that she was
in the picture that kamala saw her with the flower
in her hair and her grandmother had been drawing
those pictures based on her memory the rose in her
hair is meant to be from the roses in their garden
and i'm assuming she only took the bangle off
like very very briefly because you see kamala's
grandmother playing with it as a baby then if it
wasn't clear why her husband was so pissed off at
the person offering them food the idea is that
they're being pushed out of their home no one's
buying his goods and selling anything to his wife
at the market because they were muslims they were
different culturally from the rest of the people
in the town and they were part of the group of
people in india that were forcibly relocated to
pakistan after the partition then they basically
confirmed all of our theories from the past couple
of episodes about what really happened to her
great-grandmother aisha camaron's mother najma is
the one who tried to kill her to take the bengal
because aisha didn't care about going home like
i explained she didn't want to go back to the
clandestine dimension because she had this new
family on earth she wanted to protect and even
though they don't completely ever explain
why najma is so dead set on going back to
the clandestine dimension i think the idea is
that there's something in that dimension that
she left behind or that she was forced to leave
behind that she wants to get back to like there's
something that she really cares about in that
dimension it's not that she just wants more power
or anything like that they want you to sympathize
with her at least a little bit but it's basically
the same conflict in the past that you see playing
out in present day where she learns about the
bengal then tries to kill kamala khan to take the
bengal or at least force kamala khan to help them
get back as i said they also confirmed the theory
that kamala is the one who at least starts to help
saving the grandmother like she is the person who
led the creation of the trail of stars the way
they explained the actual trail of stars though is
when kamala was trying to save her with a platform
and was hurt the platform broke it broke into a
bunch of pieces and the smaller pieces just looked
like stars so it really was kamala that saved
her in the past like i said grandfather paradox
because the grandmother had the bengal in
the past which kept it in the family line
you could also think of it as a bootstrap paradox
because like the event of her coming back in time
caused her to get the bang on the future the funny
connection to kang the conqueror is that that's
basically what kang does or all the different
kang variants across the multiverse is they
basically protect or enhance the events that led
to them becoming the version of kang that they
are in the future i think the big reason she sent
the bangle with her daughter was just to keep it
out of najma's hands but also if it wasn't clear
all of them within their family line have the same
power like her grandmother exists the same way
that kamala exists with part human dna and park
clandestine dna the mother is the same as well too
so like they'd all be able to use that same newer
ability then after the grandmother's save the
bengal sends her back to the future like she falls
back through the portal into present day as if no
time has passed everyone's passed out because of
the explosion caused by the bengal the first time
and if it wasn't clear why the veil had opened
and was spilling out all this energy it's just
because the bengal had given off so much newer
energy with that explosion that sent her back into
the past they have a really quick joke about them
using the find my phone feature to learn where
kamala is but that's a real thing like you can
actually do that to find missing people very
handy for finding lost family members they don't
completely explain why the clandestine are killed
when they try to enter the portal like they say it
won't work you're all gonna die anyway it sounds
like it just has something to do with the unstable
nature of whatever this portal is the veil between
different dimensions but like i said what the red
daggers explained in last week's episode is coming
to pass with the clandestine dimension basically
absorbing the regular dimension killing everyone
theoretically like everyone would die like this
and also they don't completely explain the
mechanics behind what happens to najma and komron
with the transference of power but i believe
what's going on here is that when najma sacrifices
herself like she transcends her human form to
her natural form more energy-based form uses that
power to close the portal then whatever vestige
of her power is left transfers to comron because
of some biological connection they have through
the clandestine dimension like something about
the clandestine biology allows them to transfer
their energy through generations like that so
like theoretically her grandmother and her mother
could do the same thing to her like if one of them
were to die off like if her grandmother died she
could transfer her power to kamala it's one of
those details that i don't completely expect them
to explain in the final episode they might wait
to like the captain marvel 2 movie the marvels to
explain everything because part of the reason for
making her powers work this way making her from an
alternate dimension is just a flow with the plot
of that movie the obvious big connection here to
the captain marvel 2 movie is it connecting with
what's happening in the shangshi movie because
captain marvel very literally appeared in the
post-credits scene teasing the origin of the ten
rings in this alternate dimension issues that we
don't know exactly who the signal is being sent
to just the idea that it's being sent to whoever
created the ten rings with the symbols on the
ten rings being very similar to the symbol on
the bengal and then both coming from the ancient
past many hundreds of years before they found
the bengal in the ten rings temple a lot of people
also now wondering if the blue arm that they found
it on is atlantean because of what's happening in
black panther two with the atlanteans the mother
the grandmother are able to reconcile like the
mother sees everything is real and i think that's
the reason why she has the picture with her like
the great grandmother gives her the picture of her
great grandfather to give to her grandmother in
the future but it's more about making the mother
reveal that all the stories were true everything
that kamala says and everything that just happened
actually did happen because that was a big source
of conflict for them when she was growing up like
her mother said that growing up she never believed
the crazy stories about their family but now
obviously she saw it happen so she believes it
when red dagger is saying goodbye he says the us
government has warrants out for his arrest i think
we're meant to assume that the red daggers group
has also been active inside the united states in
the past just chasing down those other clandestine
and that's where those warrants came from he
also winds up giving kamala the red scarf that
becomes part of her upgraded comic book accurate
costume that you see in the comics and they have
this funnier moment where they explained that her
broken necklace that she had worn this whole time
which translates to her name basically broke but
it broke into the shape of the ms marvel comic
book symbol so it's a funny way of saying that
she's going to be running around in the future
fighting crime wearing her name in the way that
say like captain america runs around with the a
on his costume like running around with his name
on his costume they have a bunch of funny pictures
of her mother as a teenager the tickets as she
explains in the photo album here are bon jovi
tickets and then they have the tag scene at the
end with the powered up comrade going to bruno for
help because at least for right now they want to
explain that komron is a good person and he wants
to help kamala khan and obviously escape damage
control because now that most of the clandestines
seem like they're dead it sounds like the big
threat in the finale is going to be damage control
then i think most of you probably understood the
actual argon joke here like it's just a regular
chemistry joke all the best science jokes are
gone are gone as in not here it's kind of like a
dumb chemistry joke like a dad joke they're really
just using this moment to kind of clown on comrade
and just show you that he's kind of a meathead
comrade not getting it like argon out one of
my favorite elements too also thinking the nikola
tesla poster is because he's a tesla car fan like
yes the car company is named after nikola tesla
but that's not why he had the poster on his wall
that i don't remember if the series has referenced
bruno's parents being dead in the past but he says
his parents are gone so they're either dead or
they're just completely gone and he's probably
living with his relatives like he wouldn't be
living completely on his own then mention the
devil and he shall appear because the minute that
they mention damage control one of the stark tech
drones in black like a stealth drone shows up
tracking comron he uses his power to try and stop
it causing it to retaliate so r.i.p to bruno shop
i talked about this in an earlier episode even
though spider-man no way home changed the timeline
so like the edith glasses didn't wind up happening
with a version of peter parker because now in this
timeline iron man would have never known a version
of peter parker they wouldn't have had that same
kind of relationship together but it seems like
iron man still created the drones ultimately and
then they were co-opted by damage control so these
are all meant to be like stark industries drones
just repurposed for whatever they want them to do
the end credits for the episode are meant to
be the same end credits that we saw during last
week's episode the ones with all the comic book
art but done as if it were happening in karachi
because they literally traveled to karachi and
yes the green ms marvel symbol at the end with
the star is meant to be a reference to the flag
of pakistan overall it was probably one of the
shortest episodes of the series so far it was
only about a half an hour long without the credits
there's still a ton of questions about how all
this connects with what was happening during the
shangshi movie the 10 rings obviously did a lot
of connections and easter eggs to other marvel
stuff like i said the iron man connection with
the stark tech drones all the connections to the
captain marvel 2 movie i think that captain marvel
will wind up showing up in a cameo scene during
the finale two paying off the comic book easter
egg with her showing up to talk to kamala khan
because the whole idea is that she's this fangirl
of captain marvel they spent so much time talking
about her in episode one she ultimately bases her
name on captain marvel calling herself ms marvel
so probably one of the easiest predictions to make
is that brie larson will have some kind of cameo
scene in the finale and it'll lead into what
happens during the captain marvel 2 movie like
it'll be some teaser for that but if you spotted
any big easter eggs in the episode that i didn't
talk about in the video just write them below in
the comments or if you have any questions about
what happened in the episode and also post all
your theories about what the post credit scenes
are going to be in the finale like what are the
cameo scenes going to be who are you expecting
to see show up in the last episode and because
so much of the plot now turns on this alternate
dimension of the clandestine it sounds like that's
going to be a big thing during captain marvel 2 or
at least some of the newer energy from this other
dimension but you can post all your theories about
that in the comments too thor love and thunder
is coming out this week so i'll do my full post
credit scene video for breakdown easter eggs
for the movie when it comes out in a couple days
i just posted my thor love and thunder
review video you can click here for that
and you can click here for my brand new loki
season 2 first look and easter eggs video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!